[Music]
of all the shocking and macabre
experiences of my life
the one that i shall longest remember
occurred a few years ago in paris
like hundreds of other young americans i
was then an art student
in the french metropolis having been
there several years
i had acquired a fair speaking knowledge
of the language as well as an
acquaintance with many odd nooks and
corners
of the city which i used to visit for my
own amusement
i did not foresee that one of my strolls
of discovery through the winding ancient
streets
was to involve me in a dread adventure
one rather hot and sultry august evening
just as twilight was softening the hard
stone outlines of the buildings
i was making a random pilgrimage through
an old part of the city
i did not know just where i was but
suddenly i found myself in a district i
did not remember ever having seen before
emerging from the mouth of a crazy
twisted alley i found myself in a large
stone court
opposite a grim but imposing edifice
four or five stories high it looked like
the typical medieval fortress
each of its four corners was topped by a
round tower
which with mere slits of windows and
pointed spear sharp peaks
might have come straight from the middle
ages the central structure also rose to
a sharp spire
surmounting all the others its meager
windows
not quite so narrow as those of the
towers were crossed by iron bars on the
two lower floors
but what most surprised me were the
three successive rows of stone ramparts
each higher than the one before it which
separated me from the castle
and the musket-bearing centuries that
stood in front
strange i thought i've never run across
this place before
nor even heard it mentioned but
curiosity is one of my
dominant traits i wouldn't have been
true to my own nature if i had not
started toward the castle
i will admit that i did have a creepy
sensation as i approached
something within me seemed to pull me
back as if a voice were crying keep away
keep away
but a counter voice probably some devil
inside me
was urging me forward i fully expected
to be stopped by the guards
but they stood sleepily at their posts
and appeared not even to notice me
so stiff and motionless they seemed that
a fleeting doubt came over me as to
whether they were live men or dummies
besides there was something peculiar
about their uniforms
in the gathering twilight it was hard to
observe details
but their clothes seemed rather like
museum pieces
almost what you would have expected of
guards a hundred years ago
not being challenged i kept on i knew
that it was reckless of me
but i passed through a first gate a
second and a third
and not a hand or a voice was lifted to
stop me
by the time i was in the castle itself
and saw its grey stone walls enclosing
me in a sort of heavy dusk
a chill was stealing along my spine
despite the heat
a musty smell as if from bygone
centuries was in my nostrils
and a cold sweat burst out on my brows
and the palms of my hands
as i turned to leave it was then that i
first heard the voice from above
it was a plaintive voice in a woman's
melodious tones
sir sir what is it
i called back almost automatically but
the chill along my spine deepened
more of that clammy sweat came out of my
brow
i'm sorry to own it but i had no wish
except to dash out through the three
gates
past the stone ramparts and onto the
known safe streets
yet within me some resisting voice cried
out jim you crazy fool what are you
scared of
and so though shuddering i held my
ground
will you come up sir the voice invited
in the same soft feminine tones
which yet had an urgency that i could
not miss
frankness compels me to admit that there
was nothing i desired less than to
ascend those winding old stone stairs in
the semi-darkness
but here was a challenge to my manliness
if i dashed away like a trembling rabbit
i'd never again be able to look myself
in the face
besides might someone really be needing
my help
while my mind traveled romantically
between hopes of rescuing maiden
innocents
and fears of being trapped into some
monstrous den
i took my way slowly up the spiral
stairs
through foot deep slits and the rock
walls barely enough light was admitted
to enable me to stumble up in a shadowy
sort of way
nevertheless something within me still
seemed to be pressing my reluctant feet
forward
at the same time as a counterforce
screamed that i was the world's prize
fool
and would race away if i valued my skin
that climb up the old stairway seemed
never-ending although actually i could
not have mounted more than two or three
flights
once or twice owing to some irregularity
in the stone
i stumbled and almost fell here mister
here
the woman's voice kept encouraging and
if it hadn't been for that repeated
summons
surely my courage would have given out
even so i noted something a little
strange about the voice
the tones not quite those of the
parisian french i had learned to speak
the speaker apparently had a slight
foreign accent
at last puffing a little i found myself
in a tower room
a small chamber whose round stone walls
were slitted with just
windows enough to make the outlines of
objects mistily visible
the place was without furniture except
for a bare table and several chairs near
the further wall but what drew my
attention what held me galvanized
were the human occupants so as to see
them more clearly
i flashed on my cigarette lighter at
which they drew back in a wide-mouthed
startled sort of way as if they had
never seen such a device before
but in that glimpse of a few seconds
before i let the flame die out
i clearly saw the faces the fat solid
looking man with double chins and a
beefy complexion
the alert bright-eyed boy of seven or
eight and a girl of fourteen or fifteen
and the two women the younger of a
rather commonplace appearance
but the elder have a striking aspect
almost regal
in the proud tilt of the shapely head
the lovely contours of the cheeks and
lips
and the imperious flash of eyes that
seemed made to command
oh sir she exclaimed thank you sir thank
you very much
all at once it struck me that there was
something unutterably sad about the
tones something unspeakably sad too in
the looks of the two women and the man
something bleak that seemed to pervade
the atmosphere like a dissolved essence
until i caught its contagion and felt as
if the whole world's sorrow were
pressing down upon my head
now as never before i wanted to flee but
something held me rooted to the spot
i was like a man in a dread dream who
knows he is dreaming and yet cannot
awaken
repelled and at the same time fascinated
i watched the elder woman approach
without flung arms
there was let me not deny it a seductive
charm about her glowing femininity
although she was no longer young i took
her to be somewhere in the nether years
just beyond
35 there was something extraordinarily
appealing and sweet
and the smile which she flashed upon me
a plaintiff smile as of one who looks at
you from depths of unbearable suffering
at the same time there was something
that drew me to her held me spellbound
with a magnetic compulsion
i could have imagined men easily and
willingly enslaved to that woman
sir she pleaded and for the sake of
convenience i give the english
equivalent of her words
sir they have ringed us around what are
we to do
in the name of the good lord what are we
to do
they permit us not even a newspaper sir
rumbled the heavy voice of the man
as his portly form slouched forward they
stand over us all the time
we have no privacy except in our beds
put in the younger woman
with a despairing gesture of one bony
hand
they inspect all our food every bit of
bread and meat
suspecting it may contain secret papers
the elder woman lamented
worse still our doors are all locked
from outside
we can hardly move a step without being
trailed by a guard
we cannot read we can hardly think
without being inspected
oh was ever anyone tormented with such
vile persecution
was anyone ever tormented with such vile
persecution
the second lady took up the cry in a
thin wailing voice that sent the
shutters again
coursing down my spine as if by instinct
i was backing toward the door
i wondered if i were not the victim of
some frightful hallucination
but what do you want me to do i blurted
out as with one hand i groped behind me
for the doorknob
what do we want you to do sir groaned
the elder woman
speak with them plead with them beg them
to treat us like human beings
not like beasts and cages but who am i
to speak to
who are they what do you mean madam
who but our persecutors our oppressors
who but our persecutors our oppressors
echoed the other woman with a ghostly
repetition of the words
by this time it was so dark that the
five persons made but
shadows and distinctly seen against the
dungeon-like gloom
there was no arguing now with my fear it
was taking command of me
the next instant had the man not surmise
my thoughts by some clairvoyant
perception
i would have left the dolores strangers
to their fate and dashed pal-meld on the
tower stairs
hold sir his voice detained me it is
growing late
we need a light and then with startled
eyes
i witnessed one of the eeriest one of
the most inexplicable incidents of all
suddenly though i had seen no lantern
there was a light in the room
it was a sort of gray white
phosphorescence midway between the hue
of a light fog and that of pewter
and it seemed to come from nowhere in
particular but filled the room with a
fluctuating radiance
at times bright enough to reveal every
object at times permitting everything to
sink back
almost into invisibility by this
illumination
all things even the man's beefy face
took on a ghastly pallor
my own hand outstretched in a gesture of
spontaneous horror
startled me with its pale spectral
quality
do not be afraid sir one of the women
spoke reassuringly
they will not find you the guards were
sleeping else you could not have come up
you were heaven sent to help us in our
need
my knees quivering beneath me i did not
feel heaven sent to help anyone
in that uncanny wavering light which
struck my disordered imagination as
almost sepulchral
i was more frightened than in the
darkness i was just a little relieved
however to see how the small boy
curled up near the wall with some straw
for a pillow was sleeping in apparently
normal childhood sleep
nevertheless i had found the doorknob
and was drawing it toward me
a blast of chilly air contrasting
weirdly with the heat of the summer
evening
swept up the tower stairs a second more
and i would have been gone
but the elder woman crossing the room
like a flash of light
had placed herself next to me between me
and the door
i could see her big sad eyes not a foot
from mine
glowing as if from immense hollow depths
i could see her long pale proud face
alternately brightening and darkening by
the flickers of the changeable unearthly
light
and once more she exercised that strange
that magical compulsion upon me
my limbs were frozen i could merely
stare and wonder
it is not for our own sake sir she
resumed in a voice that shook and
wavered even more than did the light
it is not for our own sakes that i beg
your aid but for our poor innocent
children
for their sakes in the name of heaven's
mercy go out and plead with our
oppressor sir
rush forth rush forth and summon help
before it is too late
before it is too late came a low sobbing
echo
but you who are you i demanded growing
more mystified from minute to minute
we who are we is there anyone in all
paris that does not know
is there anyone in all paris that does
not know there sounded a sobbing refrain
but they seemed not to hear or at least
not to believe my denials
look at me do you not recognize me the
man demanded
thrusting his face within inches of mine
who in all the land could help
recognizing me
observing the round commonplace features
the paunchy cheeks
the sensual lips and dull eyes i failed
to recognize anyone i had ever known
ah sir you must be a stranger in the
land
i yes i'm a stranger from california
i managed to grasp at a straw from where
do you say sir
he asked as if he had never heard of my
native state
and then dismally he went on half to
himself
am i then so changed by my hardships
that i cannot be recognized
no doubt i had a different look in the
old times what i went forth daily in the
hunt
yes that was a sport worthy of a king
chasing the antlered stag
a sport worthy of a king and i
bewailed the elder woman her eyes
downcast her whole form
seeming indistinctly to sag perhaps i
also am changed
oh how changed from the days when i led
in gay rebels and frolics
and banquets and masked balls and was
merry the whole day long
and the whole night long too little did
i suspect in those old happy times
what a bitter blow was in store for me
little did i suspect
moan's a second woman little did we all
suspect
had i chanced upon a band of lunatics
was this old tower the hospital where
these poor deranged wretches were kept
this seemed to me all in all the most
plausible solution
nevertheless it did not explain the
weird light which still pervaded the
grim round tower room from some unseen
source
nor did it account for various other
incidents which i report even now
with a tingling sensation along the
spine and a numbing
clutch at the heart it may have been
only the wind
but the door which i had opened slightly
suddenly closed with a dull thudding jar
yet how could it have been the wind
since the door opened inward
and hence a breeze from below would have
pushed the door wider open
and from inside the closed room how
could an air current originate
but i was sure that no hand and least of
all mine had touched the door
even as i struggled to regain my
composure i reached again for the door
handle
more determined than ever to leave but
as i did so
my shaken nerves were shattered by
another shock
with a series of high-pitched yipping
barks a small creature ran out as a from
nowhere
and began cavorting about my knees where
had the little dog come from
i was certain that had not been in the
room before i was equally convinced that
there was no way for it to enter
by the flickering grayish white light it
had a sort of half-solid appearance as i
reached down to pet it
and somehow i was not quite able to
place a hand upon it
eluding my touch it ran over to the
elder woman who bent down and caressed
it
and then as suddenly as it had come it
was gone
but from someone's throat the adolescent
girls i believe
their burst a spasm of uncanny hollow
laughter
then as i pulled at the doorknob the
elder woman was again at my side
her lovely sad eyes fixing me with a
stare of such terrible intensity
that i was gripped powerless in my place
my hand dropped from the doorknob
for the first time i knew myself to be a
prisoner
what is to happen to us sir she lamented
not hysterically but with an air of
dignified restraint
beneath which i could feel the hot
passion smoldering
what is to happen to us all time after
time we hear the alarm sounding below us
on the streets
we hear the crowds shouting but we can
only guess what it all means
can you not tell us sir what it means
can you not tell us sir
echoed the younger woman i shook my head
helplessly
ah sir you are like them all the first
speaker side
like the guards like that monster who
has charge of us
you know yet you will tell us nothing
you know yet you will tell us nothing
came the unfailing repetition
i feel it in my bones a worse fate is in
store for us
the woman moaned while one pale hand
moved significantly across her neck
my sainted mother who was far wiser than
i foresaw it all long ago
but then i was too young and giddy to
listen now that she is in her grave
sometimes at night i can see her before
me
warning warning warning
warning took up the other woman come
come now things are not always so bad
are they the rumbling voice of the man
broke out an incongruous soothing
contrast
we have no complaints about many things
least of all about the food
now have we at noon we have three soups
two entrees two roasts fruit cheese
claret and champagne
it is not all we have known in our
better days sir but it is not bad
it is not bad then the boy and i on fine
days
are allowed to walk in the court below
you can walk there but not i
broke out the elder woman who was
evidently his wife
you can submit yourself to the staring
insolence of those beasts of guards
not i you can console yourself with your
fine meals
not i i think of the fate that is in
store for us all
i think of the future of our poor
children
i think of the future of our poor
children came the inevitable echo
the boy slumbering against the wall
chose this particular moment to turn
over in his sleep
and moan i for my part would have left
then and there
had this been possible but even if i had
not already been riveted to the spot
i would have been held by the woman's
anguished cry
think of our friends our poor friends
the ones who did not escape
or came back out of loyalty to us those
tigers in human form have cut their
heads from their bodies
torn them limb from limb have cut their
heads from their bodies
torn them limb from limb come come my
dear
interpose the man still in a placating
voice we cannot always think of these
horrible things
come play for me at the clavicen as of
old sing to me my dear
as if from nowhere an old-fashioned
musical instrument
a clavicen or harpsichord appeared
before us
it could not have been there before
without being seen for it was a huge
thing on legs
nearly as large as a modern piano yet
there it was
clearly visible in the wavering grayish
light with a stool before it
at which the elder woman seated herself
as my lips opened in a half-uttered cry
of horror the player began plucking at
the strings
and the strangest melodies i had ever
heard began coming forth
while she accompanied them in a
quivering sad voice of a subdued
loveliness
the music was low almost ghostly faint
and was charged with such a deep
throbbing sorrow
that at the first note the tears began
coursing down my cheeks
as the woman went on and on with her
song its melancholy increased
though it still had the same eerily
distant quality it seemed that i was
listening to a plant from across
countless years and remotest places
now everyone in the room appeared to
have forgotten my presence
the younger woman the man and the girl
gathered about the player
as if to drink in every note even the
small boy arose and joined the group
and as they did so the light as if
condensed by some
unseen reflector suddenly concentrated
upon them
leaving the rest of the room in shadow
and then the illumination
wavering and flickering more than ever
began to dwindle
until suddenly without warning it went
out and i found myself in blackness
but still from amid the coley gloom that
phantom thin music continued to sound
the voice of the singer blended with the
notes of the instrument
unspeakably sad immensely distant fading
like the wind-borne tones of receding
minstrels
only then did all my concentrated dread
and horror find
expression in one tremendous scream
fumbling and groping
somehow i found the door somehow i
forced my limbs free of the spell that
had gripped them
and started down the twisted stairs and
then all at once
everything went blank when i came to
myself
still listening to that sad faint music
i was lying on a paris street
the glow of late twilight was in the air
a small crowd had gathered about me
does this man need help a voice
sympathetically asked
he stumbled and fell and has been many
minutes coming too
no doubt it was only the heat no doubt
it was the heat i agreed as i struggled
to my feet
but in my ears that phantom music still
made a dismal refrain
the next day i reported my experience to
my friend jacques chervier
a student at the sorbonne whose
specialty was parisian history
he looked at me sharply as i finished
just where did you say this happened
i mentioned the exact street location of
which i had taken note after the
adventure
so he answered significantly
so while this is strange do you know you
were walking on the exact site of the
old temple
what in thunder was the temple it was
the old castle of the night's templar
which was torn down in 1811
at the age of almost 600 years torn down
in 1811
i repeated dully it's famous as the
scene of many historic episodes
jacques warm to his theme not the least
notable being the imprisonment of a king
and queen of france
along with their two children and madame
elizabeth the king's sister
that was back in 1792 you know of course
what king and queen i refer to
i can only mumble something incoherent
louis xvi and marie antoinette were both
lodged there before being sent to the
guillotine
the old castle from all i can make out
was exactly as you have described it
even to the small dog that kept the
prisoners company
but that doesn't explain why i of all
persons and at this particular time
don't you recall the date let's see
today is the 14th isn't it
and yesterday was the 13th it was on
august 13th
just at about sunset that louis xvi and
marie antoinette were imprisoned in the
temple
perhaps every year on the anniversary of
that event
but i did not hear the remainder of
jacques speech i was not interested in
his explanations
in my ears a thin sorrowful music seemed
to be playing
i was back in a tower room in a wavering
fog gray light
where five shadowy figures were gathered
among them a woman whose deep pleading
tragic eyes
seemed to call and call across an
immeasurable gulf
[Music]
from the way you describe it doctor the
oran place does indeed sound as if it
had a poltergeist bouncing around inside
it
thomas chadwick reflected turning the
nutmeg grounds about in the tumbler in
his gaunt weatherstained hand
which is of course more readily said
than settled for how does one cope with
such a critter
assuming that eliza blaine is host or
hostess rather
for this manifestation should she and it
be treated according to the concepts
which the psychologists use
when they so gingerly deal with such a
phenomenon or
in terms of the specialists in psychic
affairs
for my part sir if i were more deeply
involved i'd try neither
but record any phenomena in simple terms
and try to settle in my own mind enough
of their nature to warrant an attempt to
break them up
good good now can we start from the
beginning with some idea what the term
poltergeist means to you
yes sometimes strange supernormal
happenings occur in the vicinity of an
adolescent
which come to be attributed to the
operation of an alien power
directing agent elemental force or what
you will
upon his victim's personality the
picture is that of a hermit crab in the
shell of a periwinkle
only here the same skull quarters are
shared simultaneously by an alternately
dominant and dormant power and victim
the psychologist is on a spot since this
setup would be duck soup for a freudian
explanation
if it weren't for the recorded hell
raisings outside of the subject's
accomplishments
such unaccountable but recurrent pranks
as a deluge of stones
strange peltings which explain the
german name poltergeist
pelting ghost and a variety of caprices
worthy of a puck or a kobold i refilled
chadwick's glass and my own
taking the hot water with which to
dilute the rum from a kettle in a
chimney niche
built a century back for this purpose
but the hell of it is the symptoms are
external to the subject
chadwick argued and the creditability of
such evidence must be tested before we
can establish a satisfactory attitude
regarding the poltergeist
i was just agreeing with my elderly
friend when a car's headlight swept
chadwick's window that's probably oliver
orn now
i commented going to the door oren was a
strong wiry man in his late 40s
he greeted chadwick and explained that
he had learned of my whereabouts from
the switchboard operator
who habitually rerouted the calls of my
practice at my request
mr chadwick and i were just talking
about your ward's case
he has lived and worked in many parts of
the world and exercised common sense on
plenty of problems which would stump a
young country doctor like myself
chadwick cut my eulogy with an epithet
of mock contempt
and turned inquiringly to orn well what
i came for is this
eliza went up to bed about nine while my
wife and i sat in the kitchen listening
to the radio
just after eliza went upstairs the radio
began to static
badly so i turned it off i went on
reading the newspaper but noticed that
everything was real quiet
the sounds eliza made getting ready for
bed sounding miles away
suddenly she screamed then we heard
scraping noises
ending in a loud crash i ran upstairs as
fast as i could
and found the kid fainted across her bed
with all the furniture drawn in a heap
around her
the dresser chairs the heavy linen chest
i don't see how it happened
we sat quietly for a minute or so then
he turned to me
dr huntley i want you to come stay with
us until we can find some way to stop
these goings-on
why i'd be glad to only i don't know
about such things
doctors don't perhaps we can find some
psychologist
i stammered no i don't want an outsider
orn replied maybe we can cook up some
arrangement for you to stay at the house
without arousing any suspicion
that would be best after some discussion
i agreed to this arrangement
with the excuse that repairs to my house
made boarding out easier for me
as i could promise no results i made my
fee low
and only chargeable if something
favorable were achieved
so that evening i started a case day
book carefully avoiding technical terms
which would influence diagnosis
i give you herewith an abridged version
of the case history
day by day disturbance at the orn place
june 3rd 1949 the homestead is a two and
a half story frame building with an
l a typical new england farmhouse built
a century and a half ago it appears to
be in sound condition
the hand-hewed timbers tendon and
mortise and trunnel fitted
the pine paneling throughout downstairs
acknowledge this antiquity
and conceivably help provide whatever
susceptibility may be needed for psychic
manifestations
it is neither extremely isolated nor
otherwise though it would appear so to a
city dweller for 75 yards separated from
the nearest neighbors
the location on the edge of whittaker
intervale against the wooded slopes of
dawn mountain would be agreeable
though lonely in winter when the sun
goes down early in the afternoon
anne orne oliver's wife is a small
energetic woman who does a great deal of
work
though with all the stir of a wren in a
dust bath
oliver also is a worker running his own
extensive farm
and hiring out with his tractor and
other farm and lumbering machinery
eliza blaine is an attractive well-bred
girl of 15
with large brown eyes and brown hair
judging by her voice and manners she
would appear to be of an even genial
disposition
without perceptible neurotic tendencies
surely
she had been adopted the summer before
following the death of her father
a distant relative of mrs orn before
coming to whitaker innervale she had
lived in portsmouth new hampshire
where her father had given her a number
of benefits in education and upbringing
the first occurrence prior to my arrival
at the oren place
was in april eliza had just bidden her
foster parents good night at the door
leading from the kitchen which shuts off
the back stairs and prevents drafts from
dispelling the heat in winter
oliver saw the door shut and heard the
girl's footsteps ascending the stairs
then half a beat behind them another
footstep started up
eliza was nearly at the top of the
stairs before oliver gathered his wits
and opened the door she was alone there
turning to look down at him beneath the
bare light bulb
her face wore a strange devilish smile
compounded of mockery
yet fearfully terribly alien oliver
stood dumbfounded
turning over in his mind whether eliza
had somehow prankishly skipped upstairs
but was unable to fit this devil tree
with her character
so he ended up staring gape jawed until
she turned snapping off the light and
proceeding in the dark to the next light
switch
just inside her room when oliver turned
back into the kitchen his wife looked up
non-plussed from her darning
their discussion made no headway with
the matter partly perhaps since oliver
somehow omitted telling his wife of
eliza's strange expression
they concluded that this might have been
a freak of sound involving the wood
frame of the house
and called to mind reports of similar
happenings
in the latter part of may on a rainy
afternoon the minister mr brainard
came to call mrs orn was in the kitchen
frying donuts
while eliza was washing clothes using
set tubs and a washing machine in the
l also connected to the kitchen by a
door
mrs orn naturally exclaimed regarding
the condition of the house her hair and
dress
while mr brainard climbed from his car
nevertheless after shedding these
fluttering preliminaries of a
parishional call
she had settled mr brainard a young
easygoing fellow
over coffee fresh donuts and discreet
gossip
he sat facing the open eldor where eliza
was continuing her work
his coffee cup was halfway to his lips
which were pursed with intent to retract
if the liquid proved too hot
when a cake of soap floated through the
air coming from the l
and swinging in a near 90 degree arc to
settle in the soap dish by the kitchen
sink
that was one cup of coffee mr brainerd
did not drink
several minutes later when mr brainard
and ann orn looked into the
l they found eliza caught by nervous
laughter
badly convulsed apparently from the
effort of her performance
indeed the two mystified witnesses had
to put her on the front room couch and
minister to her with
damp cloths smelling salts or whatever
they thought best
there was no trace of the diabolical
about her expression then
on recovering she claimed she knew
nothing of the episode being quite
unable to explain her attack of hysteria
with this episode the story took form
and spread through the community
i was called in though my examination
brought nothing positive to light
for the record the story that the donuts
in the bowl on the kitchen table flew
onto the coat hangers against the
kitchen wall
is the invention and whole cloth
embroidery of some absent party
a village loafer probably for both mr
brainard and ann oren deny any such
occurrence
june 6th 1949 in return for a couple of
weeks with a limited practice i had to
put in more time at the hospital
evenings were more apt to be free and so
far i have managed to be on hand most
evenings
though nothing has yet happened during
my stay this evening the four of us were
seated at the table reading
or in eliza's case writing a letter to a
friend in portsmouth
a mouse had been scampering in the walls
though i had not been particularly
conscious of it until i happened to
notice eliza reflecting a moment over
her letter
i could almost see her attention caught
by the creature's slate scuttlings and
squeakings
perhaps the sudden muffling of the
atmosphere was responsible
as if a focus of attention of some sort
were being established
then all at once eliza's face changed
taking on the wholly tense preoccupied
expression of a cat about to spring
a full taut minute thus and then she
gave a slight forward thrust
just the shadow of a lunge i would call
it from the wall
a shrill agonized mouse cry piped
the orns looked up in surprise at the
blank wall and its hidden
strangely wracked victim neither eliza
nor i
turned a heating head i of course being
concerned with her reaction
while she well i think i must yield my
medical judgment and say she acted as
one possessed
as if the person within her personality
were supplanted
her mind being temporarily tenanted by a
diabolical force
no this poltergeist is no mere
prankster's connivance
a moment following the mouse's last cry
soon reached in rapid diminuendo
eliza thrusts the very tip of her tongue
briefly between her teeth
and in doing so seemed to be released to
herself and regain her own personality
seeing the three of us watching her
rather than the blank wall behind which
was a still mouse
she shook her head slightly gosh i must
have dozed off
i feel awfully tired i didn't snore did
i
i assured her that she hadn't that we
were merely looking up because we
thought we had heard a mouse in the wall
yes i guess i must have heard him
scampering around
funny you hear a noise like that and
hardly realize it
shortly after that she retired for the
night
june 7th 1949 i've been thinking a good
deal today about the human brain as an
organ
now the heart is fairly plainly a pump
one can comprehend its function upon
inspecting it
as in dissection and so on with all the
other organs
their functions can be readily
comprehended upon examination
but the mass of gray matter which
comprises the brain cannot be thus
comprehended as the source of thought
process
one cannot see where or how this
visceral-like mass
permits one to pilot an airplane and
carry on a conversation at the same time
or to cope with a novel problem such as
the present one of conjecture concerning
poltergeists
since we cannot yet look into the brain
and get very far by induction
all we know about it is what we feel and
experience ourselves
or what we observe in others therefore i
conclude
if phenomenal accomplishments are
directed by the brain
of which the brain's possessor is wholly
unaware the fact that these functions
were directed by the brain
would defy detection thus for example
the recent experiments at duke
university with cards
regarding mental telegraphy or the
age-old business of making a dividing
rod to indicate the subterranean
presence of water
these in the human brain or the homing
instinct in the pigeon's brain
suggests that certain functions of the
brain may exceed anything we have yet
ascertained
putting it another way if we say i think
therefore i
am the i am cannot directly challenge or
enlarge upon the
i think and if an unaccounted
relationship between forces of the mind
and external objects
and conjecturably forces in the
environment exist there's simply no
telling of it
june 11th 1949 whatever it is
it's getting stronger growing like a
malignant tumor
each successful exercise of dominance
over eliza's mind increases the power of
the next manifestation
which may be less capricious and not
content with a mouse for a victim
that eliza is possessed by a malevolent
entity or grotesque preternatural schism
of split personality
or whatever in hell it can be called for
it is surely spawned of hell
is apparent to me whether my terms fit
the textbooks or not
eliza and i started the evening with a
game of checkers
this would prove diverting while keeping
me posted on her mental state
she sat in the chair reverend brainerd
had occupied facing the l
the kitchen sink this is from the chair
occupants left to right
a window into the area front yard which
might be called the l courtyard
we played across a corner of the
full-size table in order to reach the
board readily
her game was undistinguished and free
from devious tricks or wild gambles
my own is orthodox too i'm merely noting
the less artful nature of this girl of
half my age
her chance came in the third game to
force me to sacrifice
if she could be reasonably sure of her
calculations
as she concentrated on the alternative
moves i watched her
though in a moment she screened her brow
with her hand and i could no longer see
her face
suddenly the air became heavy a
stillness that almost seemed sound and
sued
as if silent black wings beat down upon
the air
the telephone went ting not ringing but
ticking
as these country lines do in a
thunderstorm
i looked up at the windows wondering if
a storm was coming
but could see only darkness then i saw a
face
pressed against the l courtyard window a
white face
wide-eyed in terror it was the face of
eliza blaine
breaking my gaze from this onlookers i
turned in amazement to the girl across
the checkerboard
her face was utterly alien an abominable
seder's mask looking in cool sardonic
amusement at its counterparts features
pressed so fearfully against the
windowpane
i think that i did the right thing at
last i ran to the outer l door and threw
it open upon the courtyard
switching on the outdoor light i saw the
courtyard was empty
and the impress of no footprints were in
the garden plot under the window
i turned back at once to find oliver
oren just catching the fainting eliza
i think i did right i say because if i
had turned and slapped the face or
shaken the shoulders of the creature
across the checkerboard from me
there'd be danger of psychic trauma for
eliza with negative results as far as
the poltergeist went
june 12 1949 this morning i visited
chadwick
telling him what appears here his advice
to me was
your best bet is to find some action
which will fit all the various theories
about poltergeist
since you are concerned with sure
counteraction rather than theorizing
you must apply this action when the
poltergeist is dominant
and in such a way that eliza is done
neither bodily nor mental harm
you must surprise the poltergeist
confronting him as strongly as possible
at the moment of his greatest aggression
and you must do so with something as
opposite in all respects as possible
i agreed and we concocted rejected and
sorted over a number of possible plans
finally we hit upon two or three schemes
which seem more substantial
if they can be worked out i do not
propose to report on them now
as they may never be tested since one of
them involved the services of a skilled
dental technician friend
i spent the rest of the day with him in
the hospital laboratory
june 15 1949 fortunately no
manifestations took place while i was
completing a variety of preparations
to cover as many contingencies as i
could
today i brought back the acrylic plastic
candlestick which my dental technician
had produced
using his false teeth manufacturer thus
divertedly
it was a curious piece anything but
artistic
with shapeless top-heavy bulges
remarking upon its amateurish appearance
and saying that i could do better with
more practice
i put the object on the mantle with my
tobacco jar and smoking apparatus
since it seemed highly improbable that
the poltergeist would appear in the
presence of any object which it knew to
be inimical
i hoped that this candlestick would not
appear so
it had been a hot day with thunder
showers likely to break the oppressively
muggy air
shortly after supper i was standing up
filling my pipe
as is my custom i was reaching for a
wooden match from the wall receptacle
and oddly looking into the mirror in
front of me
my gaze rested on the image of eliza or
what displaced it
the face was turned as she talked to mrs
orn but the mirror reflected the
abhorrent seder's head
self-confident with the myriad
abominations of hell itself
as i watched eliza or this horror
saw me staring at the mirror and broke
into a sardonian smile
i turned from the mirror to eliza her
features were nearly normal
though the alterations were even now
taking place as if challenging me for my
looking glass view
i was not idle either for the time had
come
and yet my mind continued turning over
the matter of mirrors
the lore of the speculum of mage merlin
the devil's looking glass of dr lee
of catoptermancy and vampirism
i had picked up the candlestick and
advanced slowly with a show of
irresolution to the stove
doctors and acrobats bull fighters and
actors must have a sense of timing
it is often extremely important here the
poltergeist must think me uncertain
or bent upon hurting eliza at which
misdirected aim he could laugh
exalt and grow stronger so i advanced to
the stove as the transformation
unabated reached its completion
mr and mrs oren sat still as i lifted
the lid of the hot kettle
i had to trust them to heed my
injunction not to stir
then the lights went out the electricity
in this part of the country sometimes
does cut out when there are
thunderstorms
but this was too opportune to be chance
from eliza's figure sprouted mushroom
blobs of static light
like saint elma's fires shining yet not
igniting
forming at the hem of her skirt her
waist the nape of her neck
swamp fire of the fiends finding with
the room thus weirdly illumined the
poltergeist held both hands aloft with
palms taut and fingers radiating
outstretched to the area above my head
shrilly
eliza's strained vocal cords emitted the
fiend's curses and evocations
all around me stones fell yet i was
unhurt
i drew from the kettle the acrylic
plastic figure
the action of the boiling water had
fulfilled our anticipations
by invoking the peculiar properties of
the candlestick substances
reshaping it into the form of a crucifix
as i walked forward with the talisman
upraised the demonic creature emitted a
hell running cry
as if a bottomless pit gaped beneath him
his hands lowered spasmodically to
clutch idiotically about his face
his features withered and writhed
revealed as the electricity came on
again
when presumably the fiend's willpower
dissolved its damning block
in a moment the struggle was over eliza
released collapsed into her chair and
but for my free hand would have fallen
to the floor
june 15 1949 chadwick explains the
matter by calling the poltergeist a
virulent mass
and the crucifix an all-healing
antibiotic which is an interesting way
of putting it
since the crucifix was dormant in the
plastic the acrylic being peculiar in
that once fixed
in the form of a crucifix it could be
provisionally altered to the rough shape
of a candlestick
until its memory was stirred by the
boiling water when it reverted to its
fixed
shape it could form a perfect opposite
to the poltergeist
[Music]
within the last eight years the precise
date i purposely emit
i was ordered by my physician my health
being in an unsatisfactory state
to change my residence to one upon the
seacoast
and accordingly i took a house for a
year in a fashionable watering place
at a moderate distance from the city in
which i had previously resided
and connected with it by a railway
winter was setting in when my removal
vither was decided upon
but there was nothing whatever dismal or
depressing in the change
the house i had taken was to all
appearance and in point of convenience
too
quite a modern one it formed one in a
cheerful row
with small gardens in front facing the
sea and commanding sea
air and sea views and perfection
in the rear it had a coach house and
stable and between them and the house a
considerable grass plot with some flower
beds interposed
our family consisted of my wife and
myself with three children
the eldest about nine years old she and
the next in age being girls
and the youngest between six and seven a
boy
to these were added six servants whom
although for certain reasons i declined
giving their real names
i shall indicate for the sake of
clearness by arbitrary ones
there was a nurse mrs sutherland a
nursery maid mary page
the cook mrs greenwood and the housemaid
ellen faith
a butler whom i shall call smith and his
son james about two and twenty
we came out to take possession at about
seven o'clock in the evening
everything was comfortable and cheery
good fires lighted
the rooms neat and airy and a general
air of preparation and comfort
highly conducive to good spirits and
pleasant anticipations
the sitting rooms were large and
cheerful and they in the bedrooms more
than ordinarily lofty
the kitchen and service rooms on the
same level were well
and comfortably furnished and had like
the rest of the house
an air of recent painting and fitting up
and a completely modern character
which imparted a very cheerful air of
cleanliness and convenience
there had been just enough of the fuss
of settling agreeably to occupy us and
to give a pleasant turn to our thoughts
after we had retired to our rooms
being an invalid i had a small bed to
myself resigning the four poster to my
wife
the candle was extinguished but a night
light was burning
i was coming upstairs and she already in
bed
had just dismissed her maid when we were
both startled by a wild scream from her
room
i found her in a state of the extremist
agitation and terror
she insisted that she had seen an
unnaturally tall figure
come beside her bed and stand there the
light was too faint to enable her to
define anything respecting this
apparition
beyond the fact of her having most
distinctly seen such a shape
colorless from the insufficiency of the
light to disclose more than its dark
outline
we both endeavored to reassure her the
room once more looked so cheerful in the
candlelight
that we were quite uninfluenced by the
contagion of her terrors
the movements and voices of the servants
downstairs still getting things into
their places
and completing our comfortable
arrangements had also their effect in
stealing us against
any such influence and we set the whole
thing down as a dream
or an imperfectly seen outline of the
bed curtains
when however we were alone my wife
reiterated still in great agitation
her clear assertion that she had most
positively seen
being at the time as completely awake as
she ever was
precisely what she had described to us
and in this conviction she continued
perfectly firm
a day or two after this it came out that
our servants were under an apprehension
that somehow or other thieves had
established a secret mode of access to
the lower part of the house
the butler smith had seen an ill-looking
woman in his room on the first night of
our arrival
and he and other servants constantly saw
for many days subsequently
glimpses of a retreating figure which
corresponded with that so seen by him
passing through a passage which led to a
back area in which were some coal vaults
this figure was seen always in the act
of retreating its back turned
generally getting round the corner of
the passage into the area in a stealthy
and hurried way
and when closely followed imperfectly
seen again
entering one of the coal vaults and when
pursued into it nowhere to be found
the idea of anything supernatural in the
matter had
strange to say not yet entered the mind
of any one of the servants
they had heard some stories of smugglers
having secret passages into houses
and using their means of access for
purposes of pillage
or with a view to frighten superstitious
people out of houses which they needed
for their own objects
and a suspicion of similar practices
here caused them extreme uneasiness
the apparent anxiety also manifested by
this retreating figure to escape
observation and her always appearing to
make her egress at the same point
favored this romantic hypothesis the men
however made a most careful examination
of the back area
and of the coal vault with a view to
discover some mode of egress
but entirely without success on the
contrary the result was so far as it
went
subversive of the theory solid masonry
met them on every hand
i called the man smith up to hear from
his own lips the particulars of what he
had seen
and certainly his report was very
curious
i give it as literally as my memory
enables me
his son slept in the same room and was
sound asleep
but he lay awake as men sometimes will
on a change of bed and having many
things on his mind
he was lying with his face towards the
wall but observing a light and some
little stir in the room
he turned round in his bed and saw the
figure of a woman
squalid and ragged in dress her figure
rather low and broad
as well as i recollect she had something
either a cloak or a shawl on
and wore a bonnet her back was turned
and she appeared to be searching or
rummaging for something on the floor
and without appearing to observe him she
turned in doing so towards him
the light which was more like the
intense glow of a coal as he described
it
being of a deep red color proceeded from
the hollow of her hand
which she held beside her head and he
saw her perfectly distinctly
she appeared middle-aged was deeply
pitted with the smallpox
and blind in one eye his phrase in
describing her general appearance was
that she was a miserable poor looking
creature he was under the impression
that she must be the woman who had been
left by the proprietor in charge of the
house
and who had that evening after having
given up the keys
remained for some little time with the
female servants
he coughed therefore to apprise her of
his presence and turned again towards
the wall
when he again looked round she and the
light were gone
and odd as was her method of lighting
herself in her search the circumstances
excited neither uneasiness nor curiosity
in his mind
until he discovered next morning that
the woman in question had left the house
long before he had gone to bed
i examined the man very closely as to
the appearance of the person who had
visited him
and the result was what i have described
it struck me as an odd thing
that even then considering how prone to
superstition persons in his rank of life
usually are
he did not seem to suspect anything
supernatural in the occurrence
and on the contrary was thoroughly
persuaded that his visitant was a living
person
who had got into the house by some
hidden entrance
on sunday on his return from his place
of worship
he told me that when the service was
ended and the congregation making their
way slowly out
he saw the very woman in the crowd and
kept his eye upon her for several
minutes
but such was the crush that all his
efforts to reach her were unavailing
and when he got into the open street she
was gone
he was quite positive as to having
distinctly seen her however for
several minutes and scouted the
possibility of any mistake as to
identity
and fully impressed with the substantial
and living reality of his visitant
he was very much provoked at her having
escaped him
he made inquiries also in the
neighborhood but could procure no
information
nor hear of any other persons having
seen any woman corresponding with his
visitant
the cook and the housemaid occupied a
bedroom on the kitchen floor
it had whitewashed walls and they were
actually terrified by the appearance of
the shadow of a woman
passing and re-passing across the
sidewall opposite to their beds
they suspected that this had been going
on much longer than they were aware
for its presence was discovered by a
sort of accident
its movements happening to take a
direction and distinct opposition to
theirs
this shadow always moved upon one
particular wall
returning after short intervals and
causing them extreme terror
they placed the candle as the most
obvious specific
so close to the infested wall that the
flame all but touched it
and believed for some time that they had
effectually got rid of this annoyance
but one night notwithstanding this
arrangement of the light
the shadow returned passing and
re-passing is heretofore upon the same
wall
although their only candle was burning
within an inch of it and it was obvious
that no substance capable of casting
such a shadow could have interposed
and indeed as they described it the
shadows seemed to have no sort of
relation to the position of the light
and appeared as i have said in manifest
defiance of the laws of optics
i ought to mention that the housemaid
was a particularly fearless sort of
person
as well as a very honest one and her
companion the cook
a scrupulously religious woman and both
agreed in every particular in their
relation of what occurred
meanwhile the nursery was not without
its annoyances
though as yet of a comparatively trivial
kind
sometimes at night the handle of the
door was turned hurriedly
as if by a person trying to come in and
at others a knocking was made at it
these sounds occurred after the children
had settled to sleep
and while the nurse still remained awake
whenever she called to ask who was there
the sound ceased but several times and
particularly at first
she was under the impression that they
were caused by her mistress
who would come to see the children and
thus impressed she had got up and opened
the door
expecting to see her but discovering
only darkness
and receiving no answer to her inquiries
with respect to this nurse i must
mention that i believe no more perfectly
trustworthy servant was ever employed in
her capacity
and in addition to her integrity she was
remarkably gifted with sound common
sense
one morning i think about three or four
weeks after our arrival
i was sitting at the parlor window which
looked to the front when i saw the
little iron door which admitted into the
small garden that lay between the window
where i was sitting in the public road
pushed open by a woman who so exactly
answered the description given by smith
of the woman who had visited his room on
the night of his arrival
as instantaneously to impress me with
the conviction that she must be the
identical person
she was a square short woman dressed in
soiled and tattered clothes
scarred and pitted with smallpox and
blind in one eye
she stepped hurriedly into the little
enclosure and peered from a distance of
a few yards into the room where i was
sitting
i felt that now was the moment to clear
the matter up but there was something
stealthy
in the manner and look of the woman
which convinced me that i must not
appear to notice her
until her retreat was fairly cut off
unfortunately i was suffering from a
lame foot and could not reach the bell
as quickly as i wished
i made all the haste i could and rang
violently to bring up the servant smith
in the short interval that intervened i
observed the woman from the window
who having in a leisurely way and with a
kind of scrutiny
looked along the front windows of the
house passed quickly out again
closing the gate after her and followed
a lady who was walking along the
footpath at a quick pace
as if with the intention of begging from
her
the moment the man entered i told him
the blind woman you described to me has
this instant followed a lady in that
direction
try to overtake her he was if possible
more eager than i in the chase but
returned in a short time after a vain
pursuit
very hot and utterly disappointed and
thereafter we saw her face no more
all this time and up to the period of
our leaving the house which was not for
two or three months later
there occurred at intervals the only
phenomenon in the entire series having
any resemblance to what we hear
described as spiritualism
this was a knocking like a soft
hammering with a wooden mallet
as it seemed in the timbers between the
bedroom ceilings and the roof
it had this special peculiarity that it
was always rhythmical
and i think invariably the emphasis upon
the last stroke
it would sound rapidly 1 2 3 4
1 2 3 4 or 1 2
3 1 2 3 and sometimes
1 2 1 2 etc and this with intervals and
resumptions
monotonously for hours at a time
at first this caused my wife who was a
good deal confined to her bed
much annoyance and we sent to our
neighbors to inquire if any hammering or
carpentering was going on in their
houses
but were informed that nothing of the
sort was taking place
i have myself heard it frequently always
in the same inaccessible part of the
house
and with the same monotonous emphasis
one odd thing about it was that on my
wife's calling out as she used to do
when it became more than usually
troublesome stop that noise
it was invariably arrested for a longer
or shorter time
of course none of these occurrences were
ever mentioned in hearing of the
children
they would have been no doubt like most
children greatly terrified had they
heard anything of the matter
and known that their elders were unable
to account for what was passing
and their fears would have made them
wretched and troublesome
they used to play for some hours every
day in the back garden
the house forming one end of this oblong
enclosure the stable and coach house the
other
and two parallel walls of considerable
height the sides
here as it afforded a perfectly safe
playground they were frequently left
quite to themselves
and in talking over their day's
adventures as children will
they happened to mention a woman or
rather the woman for they had long grown
familiar with her appearance
who they used to see in the garden while
they were at play
they assumed that she came in and went
out at the stable door
but they never actually saw her enter or
depart
they merely saw a figure that of a very
poor woman
soiled and ragged near the stable wall
stooping over
the ground and apparently grubbing in
the loose clay in search of something
she did not disturb or appear to observe
them and they left her in undisturbed
possession of her nook of ground
when seen it was always in the same spot
and similarly occupied
and the description they gave of her
general appearance for they never saw
her face
corresponded with that of the one-eyed
woman whom smith
and subsequently as it seemed i had seen
the other man james who looked after a
mare which i had purchased for the
purpose of writing exercise
had like everyone else in the house his
little trouble to report
though it was not much the stall in
which as the most comfortable it was
decided to place her
she perimptorily declined to enter
though a very docile and gentle little
animal
there was no getting her into it she
would snort and rear
and in fact do or suffer anything rather
than set her hoof in it
he was compelled therefore to place her
in another and on several occasions he
found her there
exhibiting all the equine symptoms of
extreme fear
like the rest of us however this man was
not troubled in the particular case with
any superstitious qualms
the mayor had evidently been frightened
and he was puzzled to find out how or by
whom
for the stable was well secured and had
i am nearly certain
a lock-up yard outside one morning i was
greeted with the intelligence that
robbers had certainly got into the house
in the night
and that one of them had actually been
seen in the nursery
the witness i found was my eldest child
then
as i have said about nine years of age
having awoke in the night
and laying awake for some time in her
bed she heard the handle of the door
turn
and a person whom she distinctly saw for
it was a light night and the window
shutters unclosed
but whom she had never seen before
stepped in on tiptoe and with an
appearance of great caution
he was a rather small man with a very
red face
he wore an oddly cut frock coat the
collar of which stood up
and trousers rough and wide like those
of a sailor
turned up at the ankles and either short
boots or clumsy shoes
covered with mud this man listened
beside the nurse's bed
which stood next to the door as if to
satisfy himself that she was sleeping
soundly
and having done so for some seconds he
began to move cautiously
in a diagonal line across the room to
the chimney piece
where he stood for a while and so
resumed his tiptoe walk
skirting the wall until he reached a
chest of drawers
some of which were open and into which
he looked and began to rummage in a
hurried way
as the child supposed making search for
something worth taking away
he then passed on to the window where
there was a dressing table
at which he also stopped turning over
the things upon it
and standing for some time at the window
as if looking out
and then resuming his walk by the side
wall opposite to that by which he had
moved up to the window
he returned in the same way toward the
nurse's bed so as to reach it at the
foot
with its side to the end wall in which
was the door was placed the little bed
in which
lay my eldest child who watched his
proceedings with the extremist terror
as he drew near she instinctively moved
herself in the bed
with her head and shoulders to the wall
drawing up her feet
but he passed by without appearing to
observe or at least to care for her
presence
immediately after the nurse turned in
her bed as if about to awaken
and when the child who had drawn the
clothes about her head again ventured to
peep out
the man was gone the child had no idea
of her having seen anything more
formidable than a thief
with the prowling cautious and noiseless
manner of proceeding common to such
marauders
the air and movements of the man whom
she had seen entirely corresponded
and on hearing her perfectly distinct
and consistent account
i could myself arrive at no other
conclusion than that a stranger had
actually got into the house
i had therefore in the first instance a
most careful examination made to
discover any traces of an entrance
having been made by any window into the
house
the doors had been found barred and
locked as usual but no sign of anything
of the sort was discernible
i then had the various articles plate
wearing apparel books etc
counted and after having conned over and
reckoned up everything
it became quite clear that nothing
whatever had been removed from the house
nor was there the slightest indication
of anything having been so much as
disturbed there
i must here state that this child was
remarkably clear
intelligent and observant and that her
description of the man
and of all that had occurred was most
exact and as detailed as the want of
perfect light rendered possible
i felt assured that an entrance had
actually been affected into the house
though for what purpose was not easily
to be conjectured
the man smith was equally confident upon
this point and his theory was that the
object was simply to frighten us out of
the house by making us believe it
haunted
and he was more than ever anxious and on
the alert to discover the conspirators
it often since appeared to me odd every
year indeed more odd as this cumulative
case of the marvelous becomes to my mind
more and more inexplicable
that underlying my sense of mystery and
puzzle was all along the quiet
assumption that all these occurrences
were one way or another
referable to natural causes i could not
account for them indeed myself
but during the whole period i inhabited
that house i never once felt though much
alone and often up very late at night
any of those tremors and thrills which
everyone has at times experienced
when situation and the hour are
favorable
except the cook and housemaid who were
plagued with the shadow i mentioned
crossing and re-crossing upon the
bedroom wall
we all without exception experienced the
same strange sense of security
and rendered these phenomena rather with
a perplexed sort of interest and
curiosity
than with any more unpleasant sensations
the knockings which i have mentioned at
the nursery door proceeded generally by
the sound of a step on the lobby
meanwhile continued at that time for my
wife like myself was an invalid
two eminent physicians who came out
occasionally by rail
were attending us these gentlemen were
at first only amused but ultimately
interested and very much puzzled by the
occurrences which we described
one of them at last recommended that a
candle should be kept burning
in the lobby it was in fact a recurrence
to an old woman's recipe against ghosts
of course it might be serviceable too
against imposters
at all events seeming as i have said
very much interested and puzzled
he advised it and it was tried we
fancied that it was successful for there
was an interval of quiet for i think
three or four nights but after that the
noises
the footsteps in the lobby the knocking
at the door and the turning of the
handle
recommenced in full force not
withstanding the light upon the table
outside
and these particular phenomena became
only more perplexing than ever
the alarm of robbers and smugglers
gradually subsided after a week or two
but we were again to hear news from the
nursery our second little girl
then between seven and eight years of
age saw in the night time
she alone being awake a young woman with
black or very dark hair which hung loose
and with a black cloak on standing near
the middle of the floor
opposite the hearthstone and fronting
the foot of her bed
she appeared quite unobservant of the
children and nurse sleeping in the room
she was very pale and looked the child
said
both sorry and frightened and with
something very peculiar and terrible
about her eyes
which made the child conclude that she
was dead
she was looking not at but in the
direction of the child's bed
and there was a dark streak across her
throat like a scar
with blood upon it this figure was not
motionless
but once or twice turned slowly and
without appearing to be conscious of the
presence of the child
or the other occupants of the room like
a person in vacancy or abstraction there
was on this occasion a nightlight
burning in the chamber
and the child saw or thought she saw all
these particulars with the most perfect
distinctness
she got her head under the bed clothes
and although a good many years have
passed since then
she cannot recall the spectacle without
feelings of peculiar horror
one day when the children were playing
in the back garden i asked them to point
out to me the spot where they were
accustomed to see the woman who
occasionally showed herself as i have
described
near the stable wall there was no
division of opinion
as to this precise point which they
indicated in the most distinct and
confident way
i suggested that perhaps something might
be hidden there in the ground
and advise them digging a hole there
with their little spades to try for it
accordingly to work they went and by my
return in the evening
they had grubbed up a piece of a jawbone
with several teeth in it
the bone was very much decayed and ready
to crumble to pieces
but the teeth were quite sound i could
not tell whether they were human
grinders but i showed the fossil to one
of the physicians i have mentioned
who came out the next evening and he
pronounced them human teeth
the same conclusion was to come a day or
two later by the other medical man
it appears to me now on reviewing the
whole matter almost unaccountable
that with such evidence before me i
should not have gotten a laborer
and have the spot effectually dug and
searched
i can only say that so it was i was
quite satisfied of the moral truth of
every word that had been related to me
in which i have here set down with
scrupulous accuracy
but i experienced an apathy for which
neither then or
afterwards did i quite know how to
account i had a vague but immovable
impression that the whole affair was
referable to natural agencies
it was not until some time after we had
left the house which
by the by we afterwards found had had
the reputation of being haunted before
we had come to live in it
that on reconsideration i discovered the
serious difficulty of accounting
satisfactorily for all that had occurred
upon ordinary principles
a great deal we might arbitrarily set
down to imagination
but even in so doing there was the
oddity not to say improbability
of so many different persons having
nearly simultaneously suffered from
different spectral and other illusions
during the short period for which we had
occupied the house
who never before so far as we learned
afterwards were troubled by any fears or
fancies of the sort
there were other things too not to be so
accounted for
the odd knockings in the roof i
frequently heard myself
there were also which i before forgot to
mention in the daytime
wrappings at the doors of the sitting
rooms which constantly deceived us
and it was not till our come in was
unanswered and the hall or passage
outside the door was discovered to be
empty
that we learned that whatever else
caused them human hands did not
all the persons who reported having seen
the different persons or appearances
here described by me
were just as confident of having
literally and distinctly seen them
as i was of having seen the hard
featured woman with the blind eye
so remarkably corresponding with smith's
description
about a week after the discovery of the
teeth which were found i think about two
feet under the ground
a friend much advanced in years and he
remembered the town in which we had now
taken up our abode for a very long time
happened to pay us a visit he could
humoredly dismiss the whole thing
but at the same time was evidently
curious about it
we might construct a sort of story said
i and a sign to each of the three
figures who appeared their respective
parts and some dreadful tragedy enacted
in this house
the male figure represents the murderer
the ill-looking one-eyed woman his
accomplice
who we will suppose buried the body
where she is now so often seen grubbing
in the earth
and where the human teeth and jawbone
have so lately been disinterred
and the young woman with disheveled
tresses the black cloak and the bloody
scar across her throat
their victim a difficulty however which
i cannot get over
exists in the cheerfulness the great
publicity and the evident very recent
date of the house
why as to that said he the house is not
modern
it and those beside it formed an old
government store
altered and fitted up recently as you
see i remember it well in my young days
50 years ago before the town had grown
out in this direction
and a more entirely lonely spot or one
more fitted for the commission of a
secret crime
could not have been imagined i have
nothing to add
for very soon after this my physician
pronounced a longer stay
unnecessary for my health and we took
our departure for another place of abode
i may add that although i have resided
for considerable periods in many other
houses
i never experienced any annoyances of a
similar kind elsewhere
neither have i made stupid dog you will
say
any inquiries respecting either the
antecedents or subsequent history of the
house and which we made so disturbed a
sojourn
i was content with what i knew and
appear related
as clearly as i could and i think it a
very pretty puzzle
as it stands
you